[Music]
all right welcome to migrating your
Android app to Android oh and beyond hi
I'm Fred Chung developer advocates hi
I'm Dan Galpin developer advocate hi I'm
Eric not a developer advocate I'm the
lead software engineer responsible for
migrating the Google Play Store app to
target API 26 thank you for joining us
on the afternoon of the last day this is
where they scheduled the most
anticipated sessions
except for that funny improv one that we
don't record sorry home viewers so
you're here for what is really the grand
finale of Google i/o well let the grand
finale begin so why migrate there are
lots of reasons but foremost in your
mind especially if you're distributing
on Google Play is that for new web talk
that for new apps by the end of this
year in August 2000 18 you must be
targeting at least API level 26 or
Android 8.0 likewise for F updates they
must also be turning at least API level
26 by November of 2018 that is if you
wish to continue releasing app updates
going forward now every new Android
version introduces changes that bring
significant security and performance and
improvements and enhance the experience
of Android overall and now some of these
changes only apply to apps that
explicitly declare support through their
target SDK version manifest attribute
also known as the target API level in
fact if you try to upload an apk with
the target SDK less than 26 you'll begin
to see a friendly reminder like this and
I'm here because we wanted to keep
updating the Play Store app on Google
Play after the November deadline so
let's go over some basics real quick
everyone
minimum SDK is the lowest platform
version
your app is willing to support it's
often the decision tied to market
penetration of various Android releases
the compile SDK is literally the SDK
headers in step library that your
project links to and important one of
course is the one I'm talking about the
target SDK version is the platform's way
to ensure backwards compatibility this
means that you only have certain
behavior changes applied as certain
specific target SDK versions so
technically this needs to be true and
this is the typical and recommend a case
since you probably care about
ninety-five percent of users out there
that are not quite targeting the latest
versions of androids just yet although
we are working to improve that so if you
don't change your target SDK to at least
version 26 you might not have to deal
with things like runtime permissions
alarmmanager changes coming up with
different ways to handle
broadcastreceiver actions and avoiding
background services but there's a good
chance the rapid ways network and
battery while making the device
experience less fast and fluid so if you
are migrating from a pre and version one
of the bigger changes is probably the
support for runtime provisions runtime
permissions are really about user
privacy and Trust but it's also a lot
for apps to ask for sensitive
permissions in context and that's a good
thing for apps because you don't want
someone to not install your apps just
because you are asking for permission
for some sensitive information in one
particular flow within your app so first
of all you know it's not all permissions
at runtime one's just this simple easy
to remember list but worry not
developers you can think of first it's
the way the user sees them in terms of
these broader categories and the first
question you should have is whether the
app really needs the permission at all
after all removing
permission is easy now Eric how did the
Play Store app handle this well it's
simple all you need to do is make sure
they're after Esprit granted the
permissions on the system image that
that's not very helpful Eric that being
said we to try and use as few of these
as possible and of course just because
your app isn't yet targeting em it
doesn't mean that your users can't go
and disable any permissions they don't
want you to have and there are special
permissions that you need to redirect
the user to settings to obtain for
example withdrawing overlay windows or
there could be some procession
permissions like screen capture now
being the work of the UI runtime
permissions actually require an activity
or fragment that is overridden the on
request permission result method now
this means that your view layer you like
activities and fragments need to enter
step 8 and your permissions actually
required by the other layers alright
here's a great transition let's talk
about alarms alarms in Android take two
basic forms they are literal alarms that
allow an app to wake itself up to
deliver a notification of some real-time
event such as waking you up or an
upcoming appointment or they are a way
of scheduling work to happen at some
time in the future after the app is
closed and at the beginning of the of
Android this was a single API but back
at KitKat we made a lower management
exact unless it was explicitly requested
which makes it better for scheduling
future work now if an app needs to
notify the user at a precise time we
added the method set exact and here's
where we've implemented a method in the
support library to call it on KitKat and
above we don't use any exact alarms in
the Play Store app the alarms we do use
are inexact which allows the system to
batch them for better battery and system
health now Android marshmallow added
doze which allowed Android to go idle
when alarms would normally fire so we
added the obvious method set exact and
allow while idle to allow arms to wake
the device from doze and we've
implemented a method in the support
library that as well and note
it actually calls the previous support
library method for set exact on earlier
platform versions so after all of that
exposition so the takeaways are pretty
simple right consider moving future work
to GCM job by work manager work managers
the newest work scheduling thing that
relaunched now work manager is a part of
jetpack and it chooses the best way to
run your tasks based upon sayings such
as a TI version and act state and when
it becomes stable it will be the
recommended API for running tasks unless
we come up with something better before
then Play Store was able to see art
background tasks regularly reached two
percent more users on KitKat when we
adopted firebase job dispatcher rather
than just using alarms this improved
system health and battery usage if you
do have to use alarms use the least
exact ones you can now remember that the
most exact alarms like Waialae doe
should only be used every 15 minutes or
so so you should only be using those
judiciously
oh yeah work manager so let's talk again
about broadcast receivers should we talk
about broadcast receivers should talk
about that yes so broadcast receiver I
think many of you probably know that
right that's used by the platform to
notify and launch apps in response to
system-wide events it's one of the
reasons that Android has such a powerful
API surface now with great power comes
great responsibility and it's in
response to the way that these endpoints
have been used most of these can no
longer launch your app at least once you
target oh well there are exceptions of
course it's Android right
many of this happens very rarely such as
changes in locale or in some cases there
are just no alternatives just yet to the
broadcast for the apps that need them
for example you know like those USB
accessory ones let's check out an
example on how to avoid using broadcasts
so for a job right you can't do so by
setting up the proper execution criteria
such as requiring network service and
then we can have functionality that's
comparable to listening to network state
changed broadcasts and if you do have
code like this in your manifest in order
on older versions of Android you can is
able to connect their listener to the
connectivity change and you know just
leave it disabled and then what are you
gonna do you can then enable the
receiver by setting the component enable
setting in the package manager another
exception is if you need to perform any
tasks after your pack has been updated
for example rescheduling alarms or
updating your database you can still
register a receiver in your manifest for
the action my package replaced which
continues to work because it's one of
the explicit broadcasts targeted just to
your app now if you really need to do
some work in every package update and
probably don't because you can no longer
be launched by action package replace
events but we do have an API called get
changed packages which allows your app
to see what packages have changed since
the leap previous save sequence number
now in life running is usually healthy I
probably should do more but an Android
app wants to run as little as possible
and lazy apps are actually better apps
and I should make a manifest or
something Fred you know what do you
think that we should actually sounds
good to me first of all let's talk about
what it means to be in the foreground
because it's not completely obvious
right there are some typical cases like
when your app is visible to users or
when you're using foreground servers or
if your app is bound to a foreground app
so your app is also in the foreground in
these
sepsis your app is in the background
when you're not visible such as when
it's running a standard service job
service or broadcastreceiver and when
you're on Oh plus starting a service
went running in the background grew
throw an exception caught in ego state
exception which is not good now you can
start services when your app is in the
foreground and they'll continue to run
for about a minute after your app is
background it and this is particularly
important because on Oh the system
releases anyway clocks that your app
holds when you have no active components
such as activities or services and this
applies to all apps not just apps
targeting oh there are a few cases where
your app is still allowed to run if it's
foreground and start services for
example in response to notification
action a high priority
firebase cloud message or in response to
MMS or SMS delivery so let's talk
through some solutions for running in
the background without background
services first of all use GCM fire job
ah work manager for background tasks now
there are very many good reasons for
this it creates a consistent API surface
across many Android versions for example
or if you don't care as much about
having your app behaves consistently
across platforms I want to move to Oh
with the least amount of work required
you can also use job intent service but
seriously consider using work manager
leverage its constraints and make your
life easier so the Google Play Store app
didn't have the luxury of using work
manager because it didn't exist yet that
meant we had to use job scheduler and
firebase job dispatcher now the first
thing we learned is not to use job
scheduler on Android L unless you really
understand how it behaves and have alarm
watchdogs when it doesn't behave as
expected also use workarounds for
example on L and the first release of M
job scheduler won't actually run two
jobs it unless it won't actually run
your job unless there are two jobs with
the same constraints met
you can work around this by scheduling
two jobs with matching constraints but
seriously like work manager work manager
things do get much better for job
scheduler on em mr1 and above however
another quirk is that you should avoid
calling set minimum latency to zero this
can interfere with the override deadline
on some releases the override deadline
is a way of making sure that your job
runs with a fixed period of time even if
the constraints aren't met or you could
just use work manager which doesn't
actually have override deadlines but
what you should do is schedule a second
job as a watchdog to perform a similar
function here are a few things to
consider when using job scheduler or
work manager Android tries to detect
captive portal and poor Network
conditions but is an imperfect art in
addition an ood will occasionally wake
up your app right before network is
available to your app all this means is
that you need to have proper error
handling to ensure rescheduling of jobs
when placed or added exponential
back-off to our jobs we saw 19 percent
more successful background tasks the key
here though is let the system do its
work it's easy to make the mistake of
rescheduling with the same job ID while
also using system back off this can
interfere or even reset the back off
rate or with work manager actually yeah
I don't do that either cuz it'll have
the same results so for api's that
require that you use pending intents you
can change the pending intent targets
from service to a broadcast receiver now
if your task will execute within 30
seconds you can then call go async and
run your work right within the broadcast
receiver which by the way is a super
lightweight way of getting something
done note that you aren't guaranteed to
have network or whig logs so there are
still many cases where you should
gradually thin your broadcast receiver
using a work manager so if you have
externally triggered time-sensitive
instead require immediate user attention
consider using firebase Cloud messaging
to notify your app FCM supports high and
normal priority messaging for high
priority messages with it either with
the device from DOS which means that a
lot of them won't be a good thing for a
system help if the task can run with
less within less than 10 seconds or so
you can execute it right away as
scheduled a job with work manager there
are actually cases when foreground
services are desired or required ideally
these are user initiated tasks that run
for a long time and want to supply some
sort of constant update to the user
you know examples are Maps Navigation
fitness tracking playing music in place
storm we use a foreground service when
we restore apps after device setup this
is okay because it's long-running work
in response to user interaction but it's
not as fun as listening to music so good
news is that these other things are
already impacting your apps but perhaps
you haven't noticed yet that so in
Android and a new for new photo
broadcast no longer happen right but can
be replaced by trigger content your eyes
for jobs I mean work so is what it looks
like using the new work manager API now
if your app is running in the background
on an android o plus device the location
system service computes a new location
for your app less often even if your app
requests more frequent updates even for
Wi-Fi scans are only performed for
background apps a few times every hour
and if so if you're called more often
the Wi-Fi manager clash actually just
provide cached results now if you need
to know where the user reaches a
specific location use geofencing now
there are one only 100 geofences that
can be active so if you need more sites
in that you can actually use regional
geofences to swap in and out different
sets of geofences as needed now that
being said you know
goons are awesome you can use the nearby
notifications API and that's important
particularly if you're a certain
prolific coffee vendor you can also use
the batch version of the fused location
provider specify a maximum location
update wait time this is acceptable for
your use case and the system will
attempt to attempt to batch location
updates so that your app is woken up
less frequently this will optimize
battery use you can also use passive
location that Able's you enables your
app to go opportunistically piggyback on
other apps location updates up to this
fastest interval specified keep in mind
them but if your app's location updates
are tied to any expensive operations
such as network calls you shall throttle
those as well
so through batching and the passive
location we can work with location
updates in a power efficient manner next
let's go through some related
improvements in the platform so in the
past several releases of Android we've
introduced a series of battery
optimization features that are based on
deferring and restricting background
tasks so you probably are familiar with
some of these already
for example a device could enter doze
where the device when a device is
unplugged and when the device isn't
being used for quite some time in DOS
apps have to finish any pending jobs in
some periodic maintenance windows on n +
DOS is extended for on-the-go use cases
such as when a device is sitting in the
users pocket now app standby was
introduced in AB or it exposes imposes
tax descriptions based upon app usage
and let me tell you about the brand new
stuff in Android key usage based
restrictions are applied in a more
fine-grain way you may have already
learned about this in the earlier i/o
talk
don't let your app drain your users
battery apps will be added to one of the
app standby buckets based on usage the
system applies progressively more
restrictions to your app as it goes from
the active to the rare bucket
additionally battery saver is enhanced
in key it allows users to have extended
battery life by prioritizing battery
over everything else this leads to some
degradation in functionality such as
location requests which are not
available when the screen is off
however this mode is really useful when
you need your device to last just a bit
longer
so the features that we just discussed
have additive impact on an app's
alarms jobs sank in that work access and
FCM messages so we really strongly
encourage everyone to thoroughly test
these scenarios within your applications
and the good news is that there are
tools for that so for example this ADB
command forces the device into an idle
state making all apps doats the test app
standby first simulate unplugging the
device and then you can use the get and
set inactive commands to get the device
in and out of app standby for app
standby buckets you can get and set
buckets for a given package using
similar ad commands but remember to
seemingly unplugging your device before
testing there's also framework API is
available to do that finally these are
the commands for testing battery saver
one note is that if your apps UI has the
dark theme you can consider enabling the
dark theme when battery saver is turned
on to further conserve power on OLED
devices power manager you can check with
an API and listen to a broadcast to do
that so there are lots of ways to make
your apps do cool stuff in the
background without using foreground
services leverage the new functionality
in work manager use efficient location
strategies use the new API and make sure
to tell us what doesn't meet your needs
if by submitting feedback through the
issue tracker so right after this talk
you'll probably be busy updating your
target SDKs which is all good while
you're at it we strongly encourage you
to check out some selected modern
features on Android that are relevant to
your use cases so you have to add for
example notification channels to your
app on o otherwise well notifications
just won't show which won't be good
plan your channels carefully so that
your users can selectively turn off
notifications that they don't want back
one slide please on devices where the
Playstore implemented support for
notification channels we see a fewer
percentage of users to saving all of our
notifications so if your app is using a
translucent status bar you can use the
inset api's to make sure that your code
doesn't assume that the status bar is a
fixed size if you're using the
navigation drawer this is actually
really common now if you target P you
can also do something interesting in
that cutout area now public service
announcement you don't have to put your
system image on your only device if you
haven't used the emulator in a while
it's pretty awesome recently we've added
support for super fast loading along
with a our support on any device with
the P Developer Preview system image you
can simulate display cutout through the
developer options this ends the public
service announcement great so long
aspect ratio screens so it's become a
trend for oh yeah mess to be shipping
devices like these with screens longer
than 16 by 9 aspect ratio we show your
apps immersive experiences can fully
take advantage of these screen
capabilities which is pretty awesome so
as a last resort right the system still
provides you a way to declare your
maximum support and aspect ratio but
display a letter box around your
application and seriously do you really
want letter boxes with bigger screen
it's comes more responsibility now
consider taking advantage of picture and
picture for use cases such as video chat
movie playback fitness tracking or
Pokemon go multi display support
obstacle helps you allows the user to
launch an activity for your application
on a second display and the only thing
you have to really consider here is this
has a second configuration which is
gonna be different than the one in your
app most likely so be careful not to
make application wide assumptions about
hardware configuration and in conclusion
Android development has evolved to mean
using the latest tools and api's to
enable better lot battery life
they're multitasking supporting the
latest hardware and platform features
and taking advantage of jetpack to build
a modern testable architecture thank you
all right
actually no no no we got there's there's
there's actually one more thing Android
is actually restricting the use of some
non SDK interfaces in Developer Preview
one and you'll saw this because we were
actually warned to with like toast and
log entries if these message methods
were used but you'll notice if you're
testing against DP to some of these
vessels we'll just seek to work and will
cause your app to crash so please test
and file issues if you don't think
there's any way your app can work other
than these methods and to help you out
in the future we've actually added a new
VM policy for strict mode that you can
use to turn on and detect all non SDK
API usage which is really important
because it's non SDK usage you may
actually be happening in your libraries
so this is a really great way to
actually make sure that your app is
going to be compatible going forward
because we don't guarantee the
compatibility of any non SDK API and so
that really is it now if you haven't
paying attention in the last 30 minutes
that's okay because clearly my jokes
need work if you're an engineer
hopefully much the information shared
today was a review for you and we hope
you found the tips useful so if you have
p.m. and if your app is not quite
targeting 26 just yet it's not too late
to plan things out work with your teams
to figure out you know how much work is
needed and in fact we've prepared a
guide on Android developer sites to help
people understand you know based on your
current really is the amount of work
needed so that we can collectively push
the ecosystem forward thank you very
much
[Music]